[Music]
it's Jett Jackson the movie based on the
popular Disney Channel show that I
haven't seen one episode of so yeah I'm
kind of going into this a little blind
but I did a little research and here's
what I discovered Jett Jackson is an
actor who plays a super spy called
Silverstone he enjoys that the show is a
big hit but he also just wants to be a
kid again so the production moves out
from LA to North Carolina where big-time
Hollywood people have to interact with
small-town everyday people and thus
hilarity ensues that's about the most I
know the movie pretty much represents
there which it Jackson filming his show
going to school possibly going out on a
date but he discovers he's getting tired
of playing the part someone asked to do
another season he's considering saying
no but things take a surprising turn
when somehow Jett Jackson and
Silverstone switch places that's right
three electors in the fictional world
and the fictional character is in the
real world a super spy have to learn to
blend in as a real kid and the real kid
has to save the world from Michael
Ironside oh how can any production go
wrong with him in it yeah okay almost on
the one hand I think this is a pretty
clever idea I mean we've always seen
stuff with the fish-out-of-water stories
or somebody switching places but the
idea of a fictional character switching
places with a real-life character and
not just focusing on one but both of
their lives as they tried to blend in is
naturally kind of interesting in a
little funny just as Jett is getting
sick of a character he suddenly becomes
the character just as Silverstone was
trying to stop Chicago from blowing up
he thought finds out he has to deal with
people yelling at him for not doing the
show anymore yeah it turns out the town
kind of depended on the show to create
jobs and tourism and it's actually a
detail most kids films would overlook
and both sides have some good comedy
like when Jett discovers that New York
is about to blow up by the evil bad guy
what does he do he just goes around
telling everybody you leave New York
leave New York yeah that'll work
Silverstone also has a hard time playing
the super spy away when he keep seeing
cast members who were villains in his
world tries to tell the cops when they
don't do anything he takes matters into
his own hands
his humor says this is it does also take
time to show the trouble both characters
are going through each one trying to
figure out what to do with their future
where they belong
high school stuff a lot kids think of
around this age there's even a prom
scene where they don't show the prom
holy smokes has that ever happened in
Disney history there's a prom and yet
you don't see it occur don't we have to
hear the pop songs or see the girls in
the latest dresses and then double what
this isn't going on Wow I'm kind of
speechless well that's all fine and good
I do have to question though does this
have a lot to do with the original show
now again I even watched the original
show so I don't know but looking at the
summary of it this doesn't seem like
what the show was about it seemed to go
back and forth between showing the
silverstone TV series and Jett Jackson
just living his everyday life when you
suddenly bring the fictional character
to life does that overstep what the
original show was doing I'm not sure
this is a really clever change of pace
or if it's something that's so different
that a lot of fans wouldn't relate to it
so if you're asking as someone who grew
up with the show I'm not able to give
you an answer I have no idea this is
faithful or not what does a 30-something
who was forced to watch a Disney Channel
kids movie I thought it was kind of
clever I like that's not all jokes and
when there are jokes a lot of them work
I like that the Silverstone show does
look like a lot of fun but you're also
interested in what's going on Jetts life
as well so I think it's clever enough
though I have no idea what fans of the
show would think of it but I think
there's enough smart writing and good
acting to pull it off if you're looking
for a decent Disney Channel movie this
isn't a bad one to check out put on your
backpack and your spy gear and take a
look
[Music]
you